Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to Run Rooms.
Now, this is a horror game and as far as I know, there are rooms
and you run, and also it's a good opportunity for people to learn that I say "room" differently than most other people.
So let's go run in some rooms as we run around.
Now, this game is some level of quality to it--oh.
Why hey okay? I scooched a little too close to that picture, and it exploded in my inventory.
Yeah, I don't know anything else about this game, so...
Hello! Ah, another room is it? Oh, do I need to run? Oh?
The frick is that--oH
OH
Okay, I don't like these rooms! D:
I definitely don't like these rooms.
Hello?~
Hello? Ah, good. Oh, a no-- ooh-- a note! :D
"If you are here then you in game." Alright, good to know.
Locked.
Hello.
[Mark gasps] HI.
*shuffling on the other side of the door*
Hi, something beyond that door? HEY--oh, hi you're a big naked guy!
Ohh, hey, hey, hey, heY, hEY, HEY. HEY! D:<
Oooh! OOOH!
Owie! :'(
*Chuckles nervously* Ouch kibibles! Let's try that again.
Well, now we've got to be on the lookout for a big naked guy. Good to know.
:'))
'Cause he's gonna announce his arrival with the flapping on the foo--
*Mark questions his life and why he's doing this*
Okay?
Darkness. Ahh.
Okay, so maybe I can use that to my advantage sometime. Death. Death and darkness! Darkness death!
Ah, my favorite kind of death!
:D
Anybody want to show themselves?
Anybody in the Run Rooms?
Ooh~
"Open"? Okay! :D Oh, okay. Unlock?
That didn't help me at all! ;-;
"Turn around"?
What---why?!
Oh, come on! Oh, you're just messing with me now. Alright. Alright.
Oh, this is balon-- *Mark quietly gasps*
Hi? Hello! Is that naked guy still here?
Alrighty then. I don't know what the notes mean-- Oh key? What? Take key? Take key. You said take key! Where was key?!
>:(
I got key, apparently!
Okay, alright. "Right way".
This is?
Doesn't feel like the right way!
-_-
Ohhh!
They're wasting my keeeeys! :c
Oooh!~
Good! Oh, goody gumdrops.
OOooh. Kay.
What is that?
uGH-
I didn't know what that was. I just stared at it for a bit! Ooh, hi, work lamp. Why are you here?
Oh.
Man, I'm getting lost in the Run Rooms. I'm assuming that the place--woah. My phone fell.
*Chuckles*
The place where that running guy came from...
That was probably a way out, because it seemed like, if I remember correctly, I saw a long tunnel behind him, which means...
Hello?~
K... Just gonna keep running in the Run Rooms till I can't run no mo'!
Okay...
"Nightmares". Yeah, I'm having tons of 'em. Right about now. Ugh, okay, so these blocked off doors must be the exit--
*footsteps*
Oh!
We got Slappy Man!
*shuffling* Oh.
Slappy Naked Man is through that door, but I don't think that door's gonna help me.
*more shuffling*
Maybe. Let's try something here.
Okay.
Slappy? Oh why would I want to unlock Slappy then?! Oh boy. Well, that don't seem good.
Alright, let's do this!
*Indistinguishable Markiplier noises*
Did I open it?!
AH, I opened it!!! Oh, he's naked! D':
Ohh, but if I go through here, and I unlock this one--
I unlock it! And then go--oh, this didn't help me at all! Well this all is all bunch of bullshit!
D:<
YEEeeah, I got Naked Slappy Man behind me! I'm unlocking like a madman. Oh boy. I'm gonna die, aren't I?
Yee!
YeE
YEE
If my phone could stop falling! My phone is literally just falling more and more every single time. Aahh, something happened.
Slappy Man!
Oh, shit tits. What am I supposed to do? Am I supposed to find something? Am I supposed to find the pictures? Is this like Slenderman??
STOP FALLING! Everything is falling now! Everything has fell down.
Ughh!
Crap.
D:<
Okay...
"Survive". I'm trying, man. I'm trying.
"Back"! Okay, all right.
*Mark sighs*
Ooh, hello, alright. Ominous light. Where am I going? There's no way to know where I've been.
Except by just the open doors! Thing is goddamn maze...
Oh, I've been here! The open doors have told me where I was.
[Frustrated Mark noises]
Ohh...
WHYY?! OH, NO why did I go in HERE?
[Mark screaming]
Ohh, I've been moidered! Alright, let's try this again. So, there's got to be an objective, right? Oh, man--
Why is it it--? It just sucks me into it! I don't know what it is!
It just sucks me in!
I mean, I appreciate getting sucked in at random, but if it could give some context to the succ!
Alright, what is-- what are you? It was like some guy's ass!
Some guy's underwear. Pretty sure that's what that was. I'll take that picture. Are you over here?
oh
oH
Okay, I'm not gonna--I can't close the door after it's open. My biggest curse. Euhh.
Okay, well Slappy Man is here, but I've already gotten three pictures, like, in a row, which is good, I guess.
I don't know. Good luck? Yay me, I got his collection of private photos.
Keys. Great! *Mark chuckles nervously*
Those--those do nothing for me.
Ahh, it's a picture of keys. I'll look at it
longingly as I try to open a door. When am I gonna have to run in the Run Rooms?
I know I'm gonna have to run real soon in the Run Rooms!
Running in the Run Rooms is my favorite thing to do. "Don't turn back". Well, I'm getting conflicting instructions here!
Turn back, don't turn back, no turn back, turn back.
>:(
Ughh. Man. I was in the land of mil--ooh~ here we go, another picture! Oh, a flashlight!
I have one of those! I'll put it right next to my flashlight.
Okay, I've got oh--Oh, it's a selfie by that guy, or me, or whoever I am.
Ohh, why? "Right way". I don't know.
Ohh, it's awfully indeterminate when the right way leads into places that are dead ends!
I think I'm getting close to where Slappy was slapping.
Whoo! Ah.
AH! SLAPPY! Ohh, Slappy! EeeeeAHH SLAPPY! Ooh! I don't have a-- [Mark making inhuman noises]
Ahh, frick. Slappy closed in on me. Slappy closed in real good.
I don't know what the objective here is. Is it just like, Run Rooms until you can't Run Rooms no more?
Must be what it is, right? I don't even know what that is. A lamp? Lamp?
Is that lamp? Did I get lamp? I love lamp. Lamp's great. Love to love lamp. Lamp is my lampy.
Ooh, another one. Hahh, I'm the number one dad! Oh, this is a Dream Daddy mini-game! Ohh, I should have known.
There's got to be, like one room in here that--Slappy...
Slappy, stop it. Where ya slapping, Slappy? Can Slappy open doors?
Ah, frick did it--whoa! I didn't open these!
Uh, this is a new area for me.
I didn't open these.
Oh, I did NOT open these!
WHOA, I didn't open them! I should have known!
Slappy! Stop blaming me for your transgressions. Slappy son of a bitch.
Okay, this is a dead end.
Okay, there's another picture. Great. What am I gonna do with it? I don't know why I have these.
I don't know what good they are for me. If they even are good.
"Don't stop". I'm not trying to! When you got a Slappy Man that close to you, you try not to stop.
WOAH! Wah! I thought that was legs. I thought that was legs.
What is this though?
Hey! Ho! Hey! Hey ho!
Hey ho ho!
HEY!
I won!
So, what was the point of the pictures then?! Did I show it to Slappy and be like, "Ahh!
Stay back, demon!" I don't know! At least they were good for posterity.
Already, Slappy was chasing me. A naked guy running around in a room full of rooms.
And then he just gets angry that I'm taking all his pictures and keys!
He spent a lot of time locking up this place! Very meticulous, and I'm just ruining everything.
Leaving doors all open! Didn't my mother teach me better than that?! To leave doors open after I enter a room?!
So, anyway that was Run Rooms. This game, uh, it caught my attention because it actually has been greenlit, so I'm assuming
this is just like, a demo of what's to come, but kind of fun! Kind of fun, I gotta admit.
I mean, aimless, aimless, definitely aimless, but fun!
Good running away from good ol' Slappy there!
So, thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you thought of it down in the comments below.
And as always, I will see you in the next video!
Buh-bye!!
[Outro music]